[Music]
street art is everywhere it's global
but street art is very different in very
different cities
[Music]
we know new york you know paris but i
want people to know singapore street art
my name is zul commonly known as zero
and i am a street artist
[Music]
singapore is known for its greenery and
its order
the rebellious nature of street art does
not fit in the bigger construct of
singapore but i think that's what makes
it interesting
i've been in public spaces where the
works are accessible to everyone
what i do is always free for people they
see an artwork in a space that they
never expect to be i think that's the
beauty of it
once it's completed it belongs to the
public space so it gets removed in an
hour it's fine it's meant to be
temporary
singapore is a small country everything
changes very quickly and street art
reflects that very well
i first got involved in street art right
after my military service in my early
20s
i was skateboarding it was kind of like
a natural progression for me to move
from one part of street culture into
another
when i just started out making art on
the streets i was more concerned about
just the process of painting
now doing this for 15 years i'm thinking
about the process of storytelling and
what i want to express as an artist
mostly i'm interested in expressing the
human condition especially in urban
society because that's where i'm from
that's how i was raised and that's where
i get ideas from
in 2013 i was awarded the young artist
award by the national arts council which
is a first for a street artist it's one
of the highlights of my career because
i'm representing a community of artists
that's always on the
fringe being more in public like gives
me more motivation to make better works
and advocate as to what street art is
especially in the context of singapore
to create new things is to break all
things and remake it
innovation is disruption
[Music]
you